hi there steve steve kaufman here
today i'm going to talk to you about uh
sort of a revelation
uh here we are it's uh the day after
christmas uh we've been uh
inundated by all the grandchildren
my son visiting from boston with his two
kids and so we've had that's eric and of
course mark my son who lives here in
vancouver and his kids have been over
and now they're all off tobogganing
because uh
we've had this tremendous snowfall it
just continues in vancouver it's amazing
we don't normally get snow here and it's
been snowing for
i don't know weeks i've shoveled the
driveway about three four times
uh lots of work anyway it's a slow
morning we got rid of them and my wife
and i are just kind of taking it easy
here
but
um you know i recently joined a site
called goodreads.com which i very much
recommend
and it's interesting you get to see what
other people are reading people who
who are identified as your friends
uh i saw where velena eckley who is one
of our link learners in japan was
reading a book by krashen
i thought am i going to buy this book
i've already got two little books by
crashing which i went and found in my
library and as i did that
i realized that since i started on this
project about uh five six years ago
you know most of my career i was
in the lumber business in the early
years i was a diplomat
it's in the last five six years that
i've gotten interested in this subject
of language learning and of course over
the five six years i have bought a lot
of books and i realized just how many
books i've bought and i've got a just a
portion of them here i think we could
probably stack them three or four times
as high as this and if i throw in
the books that i bought for learning
korean and portuguese and and romanian
which i haven't done and stuff
all and of course books that i've had
before on german and i'm always
interested in how do people go about
teaching languages and because it's fine
to refer to my own experience or the
experience of people that i see learning
around me but i like reading so i like
reading about other people's experiences
so i've got books here on toefl and
toeic and language teaching methodology
and what we got here vocabulary phrases
and idioms essential words for toefl
vocabulary language seeking psychology
for language teachers learning
vocabulary
uh how languages are learned the second
language acquisition by ella's which is
a bit of a
of a well-known work assessing
vocabulary and on and on
you know things like identity and
language learning i bought that just to
read just how bad it was going to be you
know full of all the sort of power
relationships and stuff language
teaching and i can tell you
that everything here
and in three times this pile is
essentially
useless
uh lots of obtuse references to studies
and i can't even remember you know
either
proving the obvious or trying trying to
prove something that isn't very obvious
and in these two little books
by crash foreign language education the
easy way
which i picked up somewhere
in taiwan i guess it was when i was in
taiwan stephen krashen was speaking
there and this
whoops explorations and language
acquisition and use the taipei lectures
and
this man is brilliant
there is no question and i heartily
heartily subscribe to most of what he
says we have some things that link that
we do differently and i'll get to that
but he has these five principles of
language acquisition and these i think
are very very important language
acquisition is
a subconscious process while it is
happening we are not aware that it is
happening we do not learn consciously we
we work on some things now and they
don't
seem to reappear in our brain appear in
our brain film much later we stop
learning we start up again we're better
there's a whole
subconscious fermentation going on in
the brain that we are not aware of very
important point second
hypothesis the natural order hypothesis
the natural order hypothesis claims that
we acquired the parts of a language in a
predictable order
and it says there are three amazing
facts about the natural order
the natural order is not based on any
features of simplicity and complexity
that is absolutely true some structures
you learned earlier like
the continuous form or i am going to go
i will be going all of those things are
easier to learn than trying to remember
the third person singular
it is it's true in spanish third person
singular i can't remember it half the
time i far rather say
jo boy
because then you have to try to remember
first person it's more difficult
so
it's not based on the obvious features
of simplicity and complexity two
the natural order cannot be changed it
is immune to deliberate teaching
teachers out there immune
and the third point is
that the is that that he says one might
suppose that the solution to our problem
is simply to teach along the natural
order
we need only to find out which items are
naturally acquired early and teach those
first
but the third amazing fact is that it is
not the solution the natural order is
not the teaching order he gets into that
later on the next is what he calls the
monitor hypothesis which means that if
you learn grammar you develop a monitor
whereby you check what you're about to
say and he says while the monitor can
make a small contribution to accuracy
the research indicates that acquisition
makes the major contribution so your
accuracy in the language will come from
your input
activities
acquisition is responsible for both
fluency and most of our accuracy
because
to use the monitor in other words
grammar you must a know the rule which
is difficult you have to remember the
rule and you have to focus on form when
you are trying to focus on meaning which
is very difficult to do
and typically you don't have the time
then the next thing he goes on to is the
input hypothesis which says that we
acquire a language in only one way when
we understand messages
and so therefore
uh
we need to focus on input and he says
there is no individual variation in the
fundamental process of language
acquisition i firmly believe this when
people say well some people like this
and some people like that and some
people are more
audio oral some people are more visual
no i don't agree with that we are all
all of those things and i firmly agree
that we acquire the language based on a
lot of meaningful input primarily
then he says the corollary of the input
comprehension hypothesis is talking is
not practicing so that when we are
talking speaking does not directly
result in language acquisition talking
is not practicing
if you practice your french out loud
every morning in the front of them in
front of a mirror your french will not
improve now
i have a slightly different slant on
this because i think talking is very
useful because it points out where our
gaps are and it points out those things
that we can't do
whether we ourselves find ourselves
struggling for a word or whether someone
corrects us
it identifies gaps and that makes us
more attentive and so what i would add
to crash in is that yes we need a lot of
input
but the brain can miss things
and so things that make us more
attentive
such as speaking and being corrected or
speaking and struggling
or every so often reviewing some grammar
where the first time or the second or
the third time you read a grammar rule
it makes no impact on you but eventually
you start to notice things better
because you saw something that described
that you had saw something described
that you had kind of experienced and it
helps to to make you more attentive the
final hypothesis of his is the active
effective rather the effective filter
hypothesis very very important
and and and really
what happens there is that if you are
subconsciously resisting the language
you're afraid you don't like the
language you don't want to leave the
comfort of your own
language whatever this will prevent you
from learning conversely
if you are attracted to the language to
a friend who speaks the language you're
attracted to the voice of someone
speaking the language all those
effective things can help you
uh i won't go into more of this i hop
because i'm going to run out of time
here i hardly recommend this this book
and i must say that after having read
and this is a book that i've referred to
quite a bit uh manfred spitzer's book on
learning and how the brain learns
all of that confirms what krashen says
all of that confirms what what i believe
and and but i do think that at link we
are basically following fr crash's
precepts but we introduce a little
system to make people more attentive and
also to provide more of a community more
of a social support system in an
e-learning environment and we make the
learning of vocabulary a little more
systematic i do believe that that while
crashing kind of derides flash guards i
do believe that they help again make
things stickier for us make make the
brain a little more attentive so i have
to stay within the 10 minutes there you
have it i might do another one on
crashing if there is interest